I am back with norm outside an alley
next to a pub which is crime fighting
territory and Norma's going to teach me
some more about stage fighting yes what
do you teach me how to slap someone okay
so I'm going to slap you in the face
okay I'm going to take my glasses off
that's a really good idea
all right Robert because the key
ingredient in state slapping is that you
react I will pretty much do very little
but you have to sell it by doing the wah
yeah okay got it okay
so keen gradient number one I will tell
you that I'm about to slap you okay
putting my hand on your face okay then I
will slap my hand not your face don't
trust you don't be scared okay when my
hand leaves your face yep move all right
that way okay see that way yep not gonna
help
yep that way done ready yep three two
one go
hi mister yes I'll sell it this one yep
so you put your hand there
yes they do that yes okay but at the
point of which I feel your hand leave my
face I didn't do the height okay yeah
yeah that's really
Johnny Jordan wallet one more okay okay
one for the camera yeah oh that is so
much fun that is how to stage slap
someone thank you know my welcome take
that is something you might not know
you